[Music]
there comes the time when silence is
betrayal after receiving the Nobel Prize
dr. King was more frequently asked about
his views on international matters one
of them being the United States
involvement in the Vietnam War to hear
the truth about this tragic war I've
chosen to preach about the war in
Vietnam today because I agree with Dante
that the hottest places in Hale are
reserved for those who in a period of
moral crisis maintain ban neutrality
when we look at Martin Luther King's
position on the Vietnam War we can see
that of course he was going to oppose it
because he saw it as a continuation of
colonialism that the French had lost
their colony and the American government
intervened in Indochina in order to
protect that flow niall outpost in South
Vietnam
civil rights leader Martin Luther King
leads the procession to the United
Nations where he urges UN pressure to
force the u.s. to stop bombing North
Vietnam when Martin Luther King said he
could not in good conscience support
that war it became huge because that was
the most powerful voice against the war
that they had in the United States and
they couldn't come back from that King's
opposition to the war provoked criticism
from members of Congress the press and
fellow civil rights colleagues who
argued that including foreign affairs
and the civil rights movement would harm
the black freedom struggle in America
new leaders came about with different
views on social justice and change
knocking dr. King is a great man full of
compassion he is full of mercy and he's
very patient he is a man who could
accept the uncivilized behavior of white
Americans their unceasing taunts and
still have in his heart forgiveness
unfortunately I am from a younger
generation I am NOT as patient as dr.
King no am i as merciful as dr. King I
would have to say for my generation we
didn't see the effectiveness of loving
your enemies and refusing to to do
anything other than peacefully and and
and prayerfully resist that not that
that's wrong it's just that we were a
little impatient and we didn't think
that was going to do the trick
in 1966 Martin Luther King jr. and
Stokely Carmichael walked side by side
from Memphis Tennessee to Jackson
Mississippi known as the march against
fear it was during the smarts that
Carmichael first spoke publicly about
black power Stokely was standing there
saying we want black power we want black
power we want black power and the crowd
is responding and so these images go out
on television and I think they are
extending Lee striking but it was a
political change
for the civil rights movement and it was
very intimidating to many white people
nonviolent if you suffer your opponent
will see your suffering and will be
moved to change his heart that's very
good
he only made one fallacious assumption
in order for non-violence to work your
opponent must have a conscience the
United States has known Stokely
Carmichael became one of the most
popular and controversial black leaders
of the late 1960s Martin Luther King
however stood by his ideal and I believe
we will be able to continue to keep a
non-violent movement alive and keep
Negroes committed to this method of
struggle that a non-violent approach was
the only way forward
[Music]